[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages in the next half hour
and we'll see what's making the
headlines with the guardian columnist
zoe williams and the telegraph's deputy
political editor lucy fisher great to
see both of you as ever though we start
with the with the front pages
and the eye reports that boris johnson
is again set to put off introducing any
new restrictions this week despite
record high infection rates over the
christmas period same story on the front
page of the times which reporters
reports that ministers believe there is
nothing in the data to support new curbs
backlash at masks in schools as cases
ease is the telegraph's headline as tory
mps call for a rethink over plans to
curb infections in the classroom
meanwhile the guardian says head
teachers have been told to merge classes
or switch to teach some classes remotely
if staff are off sick
the delhi mirror focusing on the
staffing crisis in the nhs and reports
that one in ten workers were absent from
work on new year's eve
and more pressure on the prime minister
front of the mail as mr johnson's back
benches urged him to tackle soaring
energy bills
well zoe williams and lucy fisher are
here welcome to both of you um the
holiday period feels like it's coming to
an end i know we've got a bank holiday
tomorrow schools are going back so the
question is what happens now which is
what a number of the newspapers lucy are
tackling uh the times for example
kicking off with ministers are now
confident that new curbs for england are
are not needed uh what are they basing
this on
well um two very strikingly upbeat uh
messages today from firstly steve
barkley the chancellor of the duchy of
lancaster who said he had seen nothing
in the data so far to suggest there will
be any need for new restrictions in the
coming week that sentiment was echoed by
edward argar a health minister who also
said he didn't expect there to be
immediately um imposed fresh
restrictions
i think they're looking at the current
data obviously as we always know with
ministers that's caveatted with the with
the warning that the data can change
quickly and if the data changes the
government will act but clearly although
cases have been high and
hospitalizations are rising and indeed
ed arghar predicted that they will
continue to rise for quite a little
while yet potentially up to two weeks
um he didn't think that there would be
new restrictions so i think certainly
for boris johnson he'll be he'll be
breathing a sigh of relief not having to
enter into another battle with tory mps
on that front of having to bring forward
more draconian restrictions but equally
certainly government sources i've been
speaking to you today suggest that when
the mps return to the commons on
wednesday and we have a review of the
current restrictions part of plan b we
aren't going to see any changes there so
there won't be a rolling back but there
won't be a rolling forward either yes i
mean it's it's fascinating isn't it um
what happens next it's a it's certainly
a movable feast if we look at the eye
too
the pm to delay decision on new covert
restrictions the things that play here
are
what happened with that
intergenerational mixing that we all did
that we all did at christmas zoe the
behavior changes that we presumably did
in order to safely see our older
relatives and then what happens when
schools go back so you know when when
will this all play out do you think then
we know what might happen next
well i tell you what what's really
interesting here is that all these front
pages are part of the same story which
is we've got this kind of huge soaring
caseload but we're not taking it as
seriously as we were this time last year
because we don't think the impact is a
serious and yet the way we deal with
people who are covered positive is the
same as it was
back when the impact was that serious so
you still have to self-isolate you still
have to test and this is what's resulted
in these vast numbers of people off work
you know and that is set to continue if
you think there were two million people
off with with a positive covered result
last week from 23rd to the 30th of
december 2 million people that's one in
30 uk
residents
with a positive result unless you change
the restrictions on people who are
covered positive
that will result in most of your
workforce being off work however if you
don't change that but you don't change
the
restrictions on mixing and
you know social distancing and self and
so forth the infections will continue to
rise so you're caught in this really
uncomfortable limbo where you're
responding in one way as if it's the old
area and in the other way as if it's
just a cold and that i think is what's
going to really bite hospitals and bite
the rest of the public um sector and
indeed the private sector you know
nobody can survive with
one in 10 members of its workforce off
no that is the thing which will bring
everything to its knees so
you know i i feel like
there is there does seem to be reason to
suppose that hospital
admissions are climbing a bit but
hospital stays are much much reduced in
length
which does lead to the conclusion that
it's less serious but if it's less
serious then everybody will have to move
quite fast to change the rubric and the
protocols around code infection because
if you keep on doing you've got it but
you have to stay home for 10 days then
you're really going to be in trouble
yeah but i suppose they have changed in
the sense that they've reduced from 10
days to 7. the isolation period plus
testing on day 6 and 7. rejected what
america has done the cdc in the u.s
which is five days with no testing so
that's been rejected and and the other
mitigation i guess is on the front page
of your paper uh lucy uh which is the
face masks in schools and uh you're
reporting i think you contributed did
you not yes your your name is on it um
there's a there's a backlash at this
even though some of the teaching unions
have certainly welcomed it um you know
the requirement to protect teachers i
guess to to stay in front of their
classrooms
well that's right and the government has
argued that this is a time limited
measure it will be reviewed along with
the other plan b restrictions on january
the 26th and that while nobody wants to
bring forward restrictions particularly
on children that they see this as the
only way or at least a key way to keep
schools open and pupils in the classroom
um that said there is a lot of concern
about this from um you know scientists
who contribute to sage from dame rachel
de souza the children's commissioner who
said today she was very concerned about
the masks mandate for all secondary
school pupils and indeed an array of
conservative mps i spoke to who felt
that there is a real intergenerational
unfairness to this that this week we're
seeing new restrictions only for the
young and yet they're the age group who
a have suffered so much already during
the pandemic but b
uh
are at so low risk of the disease
themselves it somehow seems unfair that
they've got to change what they're doing
and when when they're not at risk from
coronavirus i think the concern is about
um whether wearing masks can disrupt
education and also how it can
potentially interfere with teenagers
trying to communicate between themselves
and socialize at school so there are
concerns about that i'm told that the
government is expecting to make a
statement on this in the house on
wednesday if they don't i think mps will
certainly be tabling an urgent question
about it they want to debate this
they're pretty concerned about it and i
think this is far from the last we've
heard about this uh this issue
yes and certainly the chair of the
education select committee apology zoe
was was raising the prospect of why why
are officers not required to wear masks
despite working from home directive and
and children are
well i mean i i would really put the
teenager's perspective here because what
they really hate is being stuck in the
same classroom which was the story of
their entire last year they were you
know the whole one of the best things
about being at secondary school as
opposed to primary school is that you
get to move from the science lab back to
the language block back to the art block
etc they hated being stuck in one form
room because it made them feel like
little kids they hated being stuck in a
bubble having to self-isolate if one of
their bubble got infected they there was
loads and loads of things that they
really didn't like being forced to play
outside not allowed in the library
they don't mention masks they never
mention it they never mention that it
disrupts their teaching or disrupts
their socializing or disrupts their look
or disrupts how cool they feel they've
got so many other complaints that i
really see masks as a tiny little tiny
thing compared to
other measures which many schools put in
place for really good reasons which they
experienced as a real curtailment of
their education and the other thing i
would say is if you look at the
guardian's front page on this they you
know the government is doing this
absolutely on the hoof
in a way that i don't think is true of
the rest of the requirements and i think
there there's much more pressure on the
government from their own backbenchers
mainly about you know are you going to
make a decision on social distancing are
you going to make a decision on vaccine
passports there's much more pressure
there and then at schools they get they
kind of scatter gun out these bizarre
requirements like merging classes what
does that even mean you know year seven
and year 11 year seven and year eight
how big can a class get there is no
clarity
and it's sunday night you know a lot of
people go back to school on tuesday so
i think this kind of indicates a real
lack of respect for the education sector
as a whole yeah it presumably means
merging classes when you've got two
forms of the same age range in a year or
you've got eight but some skills are
really big you know but yeah but i mean
the difficulty is that obviously um you
know the the infections that children
have spread to their parents then you
feel like you can't go and see your
elderly relatives because your children
are exposed to schools it has a really
big implication the infections that are
driven from school about you know how
you how you mingle with with the rest of
society so
well absolutely but that's exactly why
the measures should be a discussed with
rules ahead of time and b should be
should have a lot more plainness and
you know
legibility than what's coming out at the
moment
this is kind of a lot of it is nonsense
kind of hybrid learning it doesn't have
any meaning unless you say we want this
much
to be at home and this much to be at
school
and certainly to release it less than 48
hours
before kids go back to school is
incredibly slap dash the daily mirror
refers to something you've already
talked about both of you which is that
the star staffing issue
raising the cases of the hospitals
across lincolnshire which uh on saturday
um had to
have an internal critical incident
declared across the the trust this is
the
uh the um
i've written it down i've now forgotten
it the united lincolnshire hospitals
trust
which said that due to extreme and
unprecedented workforce shortages uh we
are unable to maintain safe staffing
levels including those around stroke and
cardiac care which is a great difficulty
they couldn't maintain a number of key
pathways in that um you know is this the
problem with this lucy is it the first
of many do you think trust declaring
these issues with the staffing crisis at
one in ten nhs staff absent from work on
on new year's eve
well it certainly could be the
government has asked local leaders to
draw up plans for a worst case scenario
of one in four
public sector workers being off at any
one time in coming weeks i think that
would just be an absolutely crippling
effect on any nhs hospital trusts if
that's the case really worrying to see
what's happened in
lincolnshire united hospitals where
they've had to admit that the
quality the safety of the quality of
care they were offering was damaged by
staff shortages
i think that longer term the government
is now trying to move to sort of
mitigate um
high demand periods whether that's
winter crises um public health
emergencies like the pandemic other
major events like terrorist attacks i
know that they are about to start to uh
roll out nationwide a reservists scheme
for nhs both clinical and non-clinical
staff loosely based on the armed forces
reserves or the police special
constables force i think that's hoped
that will uh recruit tens of thousands
of former or retired nurses and doctors
other people who work in logistics and
i.t to kind of come in and help the
health the health service when it's
undergoing difficulties but certainly in
the weeks ahead i think it's going to be
really worrying and the figures that on
new year's eve 1 in 10 that's 110 000
people in the health service were off
sick or self-isolating um
or off for other reasons is really
worrying indeed
yeah and i suppose the hope is uh for
government and we wait to see what
happens is that you know looking at
south africa this is a short sharp peak
and uh we can start see the the downward
trend quite soon but we have to wait and
see what happens with schools first
don't we um lots more on that no doubt
to come throughout the evening but also
ahead more pressure on the prime
minister from his back benches amid
warnings over an energy bill crisis
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview
uh with me now are the guardian
columnist zoe williams and the
telegraph's deputy political editor lucy
fisher welcome back to both of you um so
zoe let's go to the daily mail shall we
uh pressure on the prime minister again
over
energy bills this cost of living crisis
which is the next big thing on his
agenda no doubt on his uh on his desk
for the new year
i mean this is an absolutely disastrous
story for the prime minister not just
for his political prospects but also for
his temperament because truthfully the
energy bills are
going up and up and up anyway the price
of gas is rising astronomically it's
like when you look at the cost per therm
you just can't even wrap your head
around what the impact has been but
it's not even that cold at the moment so
you know temperamentally boris johnson
is predisposed to think let's cross that
bridge when we come to it and until it
gets that cold he's not going to cross
that bridge but meantime this is going
to cost so many so many families into
poverty that they've never experienced
before even families that wouldn't think
of themselves in poverty are going to
really feel the pinch on this so you
know what you ideally need in a
situation like this is somebody like
gordon brown who can imagine it being
cold even when it's not cold but instead
what you've got is a prime minister like
boris johnson who can't imagine it being
cold even when it is so but what action
would he take apart from to to damage
the coffers of the treasury because it
would be an expensive business would it
not to intervene lucy do you think
well yes it would i mean what what mps
are calling for is twofold one is to
scrap the green levees on uh utility
bills which would save households up to
200 pounds a year
interestingly even clean green energy
bosses have been calling for that
arguing that these green levees are a
bit outdated now they were introduced
years ago when it was really expensive
to produce renewable energy and it was
the funds raised were used to subsidize
that so even those bosses are saying
that we don't need that anymore in terms
of subsidizing green energy and secondly
particularly for the right wing
brexiteers in the conservative party
they want to see the freedom from the eu
boris johnson take advantage of that to
scrap vat on energy bills which is
currently levied at five percent again
it's not a very progressive move because
it would actually help people in the
biggest houses with the biggest bills
most so some other critics think it
would be better for the chancellor to
use some of the additional vit raised by
by rising energy bills to try and target
more closely helping hard up families
who are struggling to pay for energy
uh just
you know yeah i would disagree with that
slightly in the sense that everybody
always talks about renewable subsidies
but their fossil fuel industries are
also subsidized with tax breaks we just
call it something different so you know
if you're gonna it did the truth about
renewables is that they've been
massively subsidized and rightly so at a
governmental level and then that subsidy
has been passed on to the bill payer as
a result of political decision making
but equally fossil fuel industries are
massively subsidised at a governmental
level and that levy is not passed on to
the taxpayer or the bill payer so you
know we really need to reconfigure our
language so that what we're talking
about is what we mean because the notion
that fossil fuel industries are somehow
self-sufficient and don't need the
government is for the birds okay we were
going to talk about prince andrew he's
on the front page of the times
a veteran of the grenadier guards has
become the first to go on record they
say in calling for the duke of york to
step down from his role as colonel of
the regiment we will not talk about that
in the coming days though but zoe lucy
thank you both very much indeed